welcome back so President Biden's
racking up Gaff since announcing his
re-election campaign
God saved the queen man
on transester Americans transgender
Americans Vladimir Putin been weakened
by recently best it's hard to tell but
he's clearly losing the war in Iraq
don't go anywhere it's a very exciting
day around here
yeah he went somewhere so the liberal
media thinks maybe it's time for a
tune-up new a new Politico piece arguing
why democrats should primary Bond quote
President Joe Biden needs a primary
opponent who can prepare him for the
2024 general election somebody who can
make him prove that he can still run the
traps and beat whichever Republican he
faces Biden already has Democrat
Challengers like RFK Jr and Marianne
Williamson but they've got some other
names in mind like Gavin Newsom Bato
O'Rourke and Elizabeth Warren as the
piece puts it quote just as any
heavyweight under the age of 75 with the
pugilistic skills to put the current
champion through a hammering 12 rounds
Tom I know you're a big boxing fan you
know you're a big big on that pugilist
uh tell me about this this idea that
maybe RFK Jr isn't that person like I
don't understand that I mean he is that
they want to ignore him though they're
pretending he's not a competitor uh they
they're they're faking his numbers I
remember this last poll they came out
and he said he had 1.5 percent uh in New
York uh they fudged those numbers he's
got a lot of support out there and he
doesn't have just support on the left he
has a lot of freedom loving people on
the right who kind of like some of what
he has to say as well but I do think I
agree with this the premise of the
article that it makes you stronger I
remember when I was a kid and Ted
Kennedy ran against Jimmy Carter and
then Jimmy Carter defeated him and then
he becomes more powerful as a result and
then Ted Kennedy has to suck it up at
the convention and say I support the
president and and so you know if you win
and you win against a tough opponent
it's going to make you stronger so in
that way I agree with that
Killian we talk about polls one of the
things that always doesn't sit well with
me is the Democrats love to point out
that President Trump was basically you
know there was no primary no debates for
him going into 2020. but what they
always seem to overlook and I've got one
poll here I can quote it isn't quite a
direct parallel but president Trump
never had under I think 94 approval
rating from Republicans President Biden
struggles with that he 68 of registered
voters have a major to moderate concern
about Biden having the necessary mental
and physical health to be present so I
don't think those are very easily
compared that's even worse than an
approval rating because that is a direct
indictment of his ability to do the job
to function mentally and physically and
that's a mainstream media poll that came
from ABC last month Joey first of all I
don't think these are gaffes I think
this is Joe Biden I think he mumbles
stumbles and bumbles through the
presidency everybody sees it yeah and I
think pieces like this I would call them
operation
oust Kamala I'd be very worried if I
were her her approval rating had an
all-time low it is not racism and sexism
it is eyesight and hearing we are paying
attention to her she inspires no
confidence she displays no competence
she doesn't seem to even want to do this
job she has shed over 23 or 25 senior
staffers imagine that you're working for
the first female vice president first
female vice president of color and you
don't want that job anymore they
basically all left including the if not
especially the communications directors
but here's the problem with the whole
premise he's not going to get a primary
competitor if he doesn't have primary
debates the head of the DNC who's never
really around but he popped up to say
Jamie Harrison to say there will be no
debates competition in 2020 helped Joe
Biden because he was way below in the
pack he didn't win Iowa he didn't win
New Hampshire competition would hurt him
in 2024 but it's helping Trump for all
the talk about Trump is dead in the
water after the midterms
um he's not electable
the competition the bigger the field the
more it helps Trump the bigger the field
the more it hurts Biden well judge to
that point we have Buddha judge who
seems to kind of really want to be
president one day we have Gavin Newsom
who I believe is campaigning to be
president is there a bigger field there
for pres for Democrats to consider and
why are they sticking with Biden Gavin
Newsom is in Idaho okay Gavin Newsom is
proposing gun control uh amendments to
the Constitution Gavin knew some already
as his game plan out there you know he's
got his Harris looked back and has
thrown his jacket over his shoulder I
mean he's got the whole thing down if I
were uh if I were Kamala Harris or
anyone else I would uh I Kamala in
particular I very much worry about look
um as far as Buddha judge goes the guy's
been a failure everybody knows that all
you have to do is go to an airport all
you have to do is think about Palestine
Ohio the guy can't even show up I don't
know who's blowing smoke in his ears or
telling him that he's got any shot of
being the president but as for Joe Biden
look the bottom bottom line is this
everybody knows Joe Biden has severe
limitations everybody knows the guy is
80 years old he'll be 82 If he if he's
elected president again and you know his
limitations are very serious she is a
heartbeat away from being president the
two of them are a disaster and I think
that it's good for the the Democrat
Party to stop being so dictatorial
totalitarian with themselves as they
were with the rest of the country when
they had to lock us down and tell us to
do this and tell us what to eat and tell
us who can live in terms of cows gotta
go you can't have a hamburger I'm sick
of all of them telling us what to do
they ought to make a decision that it's
time for the Democrats to go out there
like everybody else and debate
especially Joe Biden who America is
concerned of any guy who says that
Putin's doing not doing so well in Iraq
and said it twice the night before and
then the next day that we have them on
tape this guy is not capable of being
the president he's got a lot of
transgester support though or articles
like this political article and things
like Gavin Newsom out campaigning the
way he is are those evidence that the
Democrat party's looking at this option
or is this much to do about nothing I I
think it's much to do with nothing I
think it's clear that this or the author
of this piece is probably not in the
room because I think any of those
individuals are probably in mock debates
with the president before he debates
likely Donald Trump the GOP nominee
um and you're saying the ones they
called and said yeah there's mock
debates all the time Kelly and Conway's
been in them I've been in them where you
bring two candidates come in and you
mock this debate before they go to the
real debate on the stage and it's very
clear that whoever the GOP nominee is
Joe Biden will debate them but look I
think you have to look at the
president's overall record right in
kellyanne Connor would also tell you
that for weeks and weeks and weeks uh
you know Donald Trump tried to get an
infrastructure bill passed Joe Biden
happened to get it done and being
objectively any president whether it was
Donald Trump whether it was Barack Obama
in their first time they would have
killed for Joe Biden's legislative
record and he has it we've got it so
I'll agree with you that he's been very
successful getting things passed
of those things are not billions of
dollars
all right up next millions of Americans
are furious with Twitter CEO Elon Musk
what the billionaire bad boy just did
that just got everybody upset
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis